oh yeah it gets it gets really dark i
once lost twenty one thousand dollars in
a weekend yeah wow yeah you want to see
not bad no i was just bored at home
betting on sports
[ __ ] let me go lose some money
betting on sports in the middle of a
pandemic
shout out to the goddamn
jets for beating the bangles
mike white you remember that game third
stringer
what's your football team whoever i'm
betting on
i'm a cardinals fan i'm from arizona we
whooped yeah who's we again what are the
steelers oh yeah in the super bowl yeah
we whipped out some super bowl antonio
holmes
touchdown
and he was out of bounds give me that
when he was out
he got that touchdown and won the game
yeah who's out of bounds yeah shout out
to antonio holmes yeah
shout out to big ben
quite possibly the creepiest guy to play
in the nfl not named deshaun watson
hey don't play with me
no no he's cool he just he just you know
he he just you know i'm he's just he's
gonna do no wrong he's aggressive he can
do not wrong he's an aggressive guy
what if he don't i i mean you know he's
been accused of being a little a little
aggressive
[Laughter]
let's just say that people who don't
like him call him bed rapeless birther
wow that's that's his nickname amongst
non-steeler fans
cause yeah no well he retired it's over
he didn't know i'm saying you've been
watching football
quarterback's going to be either mitch
trubisky mason rudolph or kenny pickett
so good luck
hey i don't know none of those guys
they're all bums that's all you need to
know
you guys you guys got naji harris and a
bunch of [ __ ] wow well on defense
i really feel bad like i'm not
representing wheel right now
and you also have an oakland ace hat on
your team [ __ ] is all over the map
what do i hear do i have them it looks
like an oakland a's hat i don't know i
just put it on because it matched my
outfit i respect it but yeah like i
really who is who do we have
naji harris
t.j what
who do we have data we need hey
the tick-tocking guy left
uh the guy who was overrated as [ __ ]
what's his name
is
casey now
you know he's the guy who's always hey
he he was cold though we still got him
hell yeah i ain't watched him since we
got rid of le'veon bell in antonio brown
oh that was a long time ago yeah so i
don't
know
would you do a song with antonio brown
just because he was like a legendary
steeler yeah they're my boy they're my
[ __ ] like i just saw him he was dancing
if neil's like oh god how can y'all make
some little yeah what if he sent you a
song and it was just god-awful
antonio brown shoot you a record you
listen to and you're like jesus christ
what is happening because i've heard
some of his songs and i said that to
myself out loud
like who the f what the [ __ ] going on
here why is rolando booking this [ __ ]
man this
bad boy is my favorite [ __ ] interview
why is it so funny is it is it the weed
i don't know but antonio brown sent you
a song it's a steaming pile of dog [ __ ]
but he's a bee he's got he's got ben
roethlisberger doing the [ __ ] intro
of the record talking his ditty [ __ ]
rossellsberg is like yeah i did it
[ __ ]
no charges no charges uh
would you do the record
what'd you do the record
[Laughter]
she's like what
what
big bad's talking diddy [ __ ] i'm on
there
[ __ ] it
yeah it's like antonio brown and big
being like
they like
okay so let me tell you this i have like
people what's uh heinz ward is the guy
though let's shout out to him y'all got
a ring behind you love hans wood love
trump
you're a real football player or a
football fan
football player you're a football fan
back in the day you guys had a
[ __ ] i mean you pretty much was a
palamalu what was the other guy the
tight end white dude i used to have a
fan
yeah heath miller
oh
[Laughter]
i'm missing he played defense
you want hans
how how long back fargo oh hey james
harrison yes
and how about somebody named ferris and
too
james harrison was a [ __ ] monster
yeah that's what [ __ ] the cardinals was
that's pick six he had at halftime in
that game and he returned it for a
touchdown that [ __ ]
jesus christ oh yeah antonio was my
favorite one cuz like he the only super
bowl that i saw you won since i was the
last so i had three respects and tony
holmes you didn't see them beat the uh
was it the seahawks and like
i just started becoming a football
player all right
fantastic 2003 at least you got to win
is your team in a super bowl right none
of my teams have won [ __ ] i thought you
didn't have a team no i okay i'm a
cardinal fan i'm a phoenix suns fan so
the suns haven't won [ __ ] and the
cardinals
haven't won [ __ ]
they got nothing
the cardinals don't got [ __ ] of a super
bowl what do you mean they they went to
one and we lost
you [ __ ] guys what'd you happen with
y'all
yeah for a second and then we [ __ ]
lost did a close game yes cause he got
that in the last couple seconds i was
like i broke my heart i would rather
have gotten blown out
pause yeah